so so the standard economic approach is
that demand or aggregated demand is that
is the aggregation of what people
willing to pay for a product each price
and the supply has to do with the
production cost and they meet at an
equilibrium and this meaning point is
being used as a standard starting point
for any welfare analysis and from that
you can calculate what happened if we
increase tax decrease task and so on but
these two forces are independent now
what our experiments show in particular
the experiments with social security
numbers and influence of external forces
on decision let's applying the men are
not independent but they are dependent
so imagine the following imagine it
tomorrow they double the price of milk
and half the price of alcohol I would
argue that people would start going to
work a happier and with less calcium
okay the prices from yesterday would be
selling in our mind and will change a
shopping behavior but imagine that this
change in pricing would also be
accompanied by complete amnesia for any
prices you ever paid for milk and for
alcohol under those conditions I think
there wouldn't be much change in how
much we consume milk versus versus
alcohol you know milk is kind of a good
deal now at four dollars per gallon I
think we'll still be a good deal eight
dollars per gallon and wine is a good
dealer twenty dollars per bottle let's
say and would still be good at ten
dollars and per bottle and what this
suggests but we have a lot of research
to show it's not just an anecdote is
that what we based on decision is not
just what we the benefit and cost in our
hedonic pleasure but also what we did in
the past and the past prices that we
encountered so what does it say about
supply and demand it says that demand
depends on supply if I was born to a
world with the MSRP or the suggested
price for milk was four dollars that we
find that was born to a world it was
eight dollars it will be fine and those
are not unique a demand curves their
demand curves that move is a function of
what the supply curve is and what the
prices are now
if if that's the case it means that
welfare analysis should be thought of
very very differently because it means
that when the prices change people would
react vigorously to those so again if
price of gasoline jump from a dollar to
four dollars per gallon and people would
react vigorously in the beginning but if
it was for those who start with it
wouldn't have even close to the
magnitude of effect of the day after the
change